phát triển hạ tần không chỉ đề đi ngang mà còn đề đi ra không chỉ đáp ứng yêu cầu trước mắt
là phải phục vụ trong việc tiêu phát triển lâu dài. Đây là hình mạnh của đồng chiến
vẫn văn được vì viên Trung Mương đàn, phổ biết thương thành viện, chúng tịch
bị bát nhân dân thành phố hồ chi Minh khi chính bày tham lợi với chủ đề. Phát vì
vai chào đồng tầu, xây dức thành phố hồ chi Minh cho thành chúc tâm phó học, công nghệ ở
đổi mới sản tạo mang tâm phút đế tạo được lực lan toa cho cả nước. Chúng nhiều thập kỳ
vô qua, thành phố luôn là một trong những đợp lực quan trọt của tăng triển lời mới và hội nhập của Việt Nam.
Tuy nhiên, với bố cạnh mới hiện nay cũng đã đặt cho thành phố hồ chi Minh yêu cầu
gáo hơn trong giai đợp hiện nay. Đó là phải chùa đọc tự lời mới chính mình xấu xác hơn,
khắc biệt và có chêu xấu tâm như giải hạng và đến bức hơn.
Dạ đó, thần phố chi Minh trên khẳng đận. Thác hỏng đến năm 2020 của thành phố chi Minh không tắt rồi,
một tế quốc gia. Pháp hỏng phát kiến thành phố chi Minh đến năm 2020,
phải đặt trong một bức trần lớn hơn. Phong thể tất đời khắc của một Trung Quốc gia,
đó là đến năm 2020, kỳ nếm trong năm 2020, chỉ ngâm trở thành quốc gia phát kiến,
thung gập cao, có gì thế chính các trên trường quốc giai.
Và trong thống thế chiên lời có, Trung Quốc đã đặt thành phố chi Minh,
những kỳ bỏng rất đặt biệt. Phong chỉ tăng trứng nhăn mà còn tăng trứng thơ cắt kết biệt.
Không chỉ đi trước mà còn mới đường và không chỉ thành công cho điên mình.
Mình phải tạo ra đồng lực lăng tỏa, cho sự phát triển trông của cán nước.
Hẹn phố Hồ Chí Minh rất định ma chủ cột, tạo nên tạo cho bất phá thức trức bao gồm.
Đột phá về thề trế, khó không ngệ và ngồi nhanh lực trức cào và phát triển hạ tông,
trong đó, đột phá về thề trế vẫn là điều kiện tiên quyết.
Đối với phát triển hạ tông, đồng chi Minh mất đường trong rằng không chỉ đi ngang mà còn để đi ra,
không chỉ đặc ứng nhu cầu trước mắt và phát phu vụ trong một tiêu phát triển lâu dài.
Hình phố cần tài định bị phát triển biệt, bây giờ điệu bị kinh tế, với ba mỗi nhỏ.
Vịt vụ tài chỉ như mại trên lượng cao, công nghiệm con người cao và lâu dịch stích,
gần với chui ra chỉ mùng và quốc tế.
Hạn phố Chí Minh không thể và không nên phát triển đất độ.
Với kỳ phát triển bất dẫn chỉ có thể đặt được khi không dành kinh tế dùng được tổ tích một cách hợp lý.
Vậy chui với phát triển bộ một cách hiệu hạn.
Gái tò của mỗi đứa phương được xa đình rõ trong thầy trung.
Vậy trong cú tụt có thành phố Chí Minh, các người và xe đấm gốc,
với vài toa là kinh xúc trời trường.
Vậy trong cầm điều phối dẫn các linh kết vùng,
nơi hồ tổ tài chính công nghệ và dịch vụ cao cao cao.
Nơi các quà còn sẽ xuất, lưu sức và nông nghề công nghệ cao được kết nội và lắng toàn.
Vào lần nơi, giá trị giá tạm được phát bộ, hình hoàn, giá cú phát triển.
Với quyết tâm chính trị cảm nhất và khát vọng cũng hiện mạnh mẽ.
Hình phố hồ Chí Minh cảm cách nỗ lực cùng cả nước để thương khiển hỏa mục tiêu đưa Việt Nam
cho thành phúc giá phát triển tự cường phung vinh, bất mình, hạnh phúc hội nhập sâu rọng và có vị thầy vi tính này
cần cao trong cậm cộp đồng quốc tế.
Vọng thầy trung.